one of the problems that's beset
philosophers and cognitive scientists
for the last 3040 years is how on earth
the brain represents information and an
eternally appealing idea it's something
like a language of thought that there's
brain writing or mental ease and we
write the brain writes sentences and
mental ease that a store the belief so
that when you learn that giraffes are
mammals there's some place in your brain
where the word the mental words your a
fanned the word mammal are tied together
with an is ax or something like that so
we have we have a big library of
sentences those are our beliefs we have
a belief box with lots of beliefs it's
an attractive idea nice has a certain
simplicity that and we think we
understand how sentences work to store
information well now if that were so
could a clever enough neurosurgeon why
are in a false belief just out of the
blue so let's imagine that our
neurosurgeon decides to wire into your
brain the belief that you have an older
brother living in Cleveland figures out
how to write that in brainish and does
all the microsurgery and there it is
written in brainish in your brain okay
you wake up from the anaesthetic and so
he says yeah do you have any siblings
well if he's done his work well I guess
first thing you do is you say yes I have
an older brother living in Cleveland oh
what's his name and now what do one of
several things has happened maybe you'll
start confabulating and you'll say his
name is his name is Alfonso and he and
he's a taxi driver and he lives with his
wife and two kids in the suburb that's
one possibility in other words you
couldn't just wire in one belief you
would have to wire in something which
generated a whole slew of
alternatively maybe you would say oh my
gosh what did I just say I said I had an
older brother man older brother I I have
I have a sister or I'm an only child
what made me say that in that case what
we would see is that whatever the
surgeon did it wasn't wiring in a belief
because as soon as you reflected on it
boom it just vanished it disappeared
well if it's a belief then it's got to
be secured to a lot of other beliefs
that's just on the nature belief you
can't have an isolated belief like I
have an older brother living in
Cleveland if that state was one that you
seem to be in we'd want to explore to
see what came along with it and either
we would decide that you had some weird
sort of growth in your brain that made
you fixate on a sentence sort of
parrot-like and you'd say I'm an only
child and I have an older brother living
in Cleveland which of course would be
contradicting yourself what we wouldn't
decide is that you believed you had an
older brother living in Cleveland what
this little thought experiment shows is
that beliefs don't parcel themselves out
the way sentences do you could take any
sentence on any topic and write it on
any medium you like and put it in a
drawer and there it would be beliefs
aren't like that they come in systems
they cohere in large clumps this is
sometimes called holism
and there's still some theorists who
think that holism is a bad idea I think
it's got to be the case holism is a good
idea that a particulate non holistic
theory of belief is a non-starter
you